let's talk about Tim Tebow
mr. Jesus mr. football he signed with
the New England Patriots this week
people thought he was going to be out of
the NFL altogether but he has come back
like Jesus kind of and already I look I
was going crazy on Twitter with the
jokes there is an endless amount of this
every comedian was doing it basically so
there's a couple ways I want to go with
this but I want to start sort of what
what's the general thing with religion
and sports like why is it so easy to
make fun of this guy because he can't
throw the ball and either quarterback
purely at a sports level that a sports
level yeah and and then yeah he became
like this worldwide sensation
practically like a character caricature
of himself with that whole Tebowing
thing yeah which I don't even know if he
realizes what he was doing at first but
like yeah he's doing this whole prey
thing on the field because God is paying
attention to everything that he does God
love sports and and everybody at the you
know I read an article that said that 25
percent of Americans really believed
that God had a head of hand and who wins
the Super Bowl I mean that's pretty out
rate these are the same people that
voted for Bush right in the last second
all right so let's focus on that then
because this idea these guys they train
they practice you know 15 18 hours a day
they are the the world's peak athletes
and then some of them Tebow would be the
prime example thank God for everything
which seems so crazy because it's you
doing the work to be better and
accomplish things what were it's like
cognitive dissidence kind of I don't I
would love to see the first Muslim
football player roll out a carpet Neill
- every time he makes a touchdown yeah I
would love to see what 99% of Americans
will probably like there's no place for
religion in football you take that out
that's not a place to do that really
right I would love for one of our people
to Hava Nagila every day
I got a grand-slam get on a chair have
all of America they could lift the bass
Nicola bass and you know I mean get like
a white handkerchief we did it people
would be outraged but Tim Tebow kneels
down and does a thing and prays and has
like Leviticus and both you know like
Old Testament New Testament under his
eyes and it's beautiful and it's
wonderful and it's inspirational right I
mean look I don't care honestly I don't
care but I don't think people realize
how hypocritical they are when you're
not Christian or Catholic or whatever
and that that's cool to me but it's like
a little show right it doesn't mean
anything to me it kind of takes up time
they give penalties to football players
who do like a dance in the end zone
but he has a set up and whole manger
scene here I mean with like frankincense
and myrrh he has three wise men to come
in every time he makes a pass but that's
okay I just feel like it's really
hypocritical
yeah well playing the devil's advocate
for just a second so it seems to me
though that we can make fun of him
because he's Christians so if there was
a Muslim player I would venture to say
that all the comedian's on Twitter that
are making fun of Tebow would not be
nearly as as offensive or as forward
with the jokes as they are with Tebow so
does that go to something about how we
view Christianity we we live in a
Christian society if Muslim or whatever
religion was the predominant religion I
think you can make fun of it because
more people are that right but I think
at this point I don't even know if Tebow
really believes or not in God or Jesus
he's like thank God thank God I believe
you know in God so much that I'm now on
a team again if it wasn't for religion
he wouldn't be on a team he may be he's
the waterboy he runs a really fast you
know they have him clocked at like you
know four second miles right in some way
so that's interesting so you think it's
because of religion that he now got
picked up like if he had just this skill
set and wasn't this this Jesus Freak you
think he wouldn't have been picked up
well he's not that talented
just think it was a miracle that is a
true it's yeah it's a modern-day miracle
that's interesting because you know
people are saying Jason Collins the the
basketball player who came out who's
unsigned at the moment but a lot of
people are saying well he's gonna get
the benefit now where the NBA is gonna
be like somebody's gotta sign him you
know they're gonna force them in to be
inside so maybe believing in God and
being gay can both help you in sports
does that make any sense yes well modern
atheist yeah I'm just not a shove it
down your face religious person right
you know I I'm like a card holding Jew
but it doesn't mean anything really
right in this world and you're right
it's we live in a Christians America
that it really is them you are right
about a lot of things that tie and that
beard of two of them right there but but
it's always I think the reason we can
make fun of it is because it's
everywhere I mean it's in every
department store during Christmas and
Easter and all you know and all the
holiday type of things that you have to
like just basically just give in to it's
part of if you're American you are
celebrating this if you're told you have
to have a Santa on your roof so that's
why I think comedians and people can
make fun of it and not feel like
someone's gonna come after them because
it's kind of just what our our country
is about right and I think if he is okay
with what he's doing and he's like look
this is what I believe in and this is
what I I pray all the time that's great
but you have to realize you kind of sort
of look a little bit ridiculous so just
if you're acknowledging it like I know
I'm taking up time to pray and do a
whole thing and I still stand by I want
to see a Jew do hava nagila after they
score a touchdown or you know the score
attention and you made a basket a
basketball so it clearly scored it like
this that's even better
religion and sports expert carousels
average right there